good morning believe nation today's
message is as a leader you need to focus
on your people your strategy and your
execution over to you Tim Cook I spend
almost all of my time on people strategy
and execution and I think that most
everything else falls from those if you
have the most brilliant people wicked
smart people that collaborate well
together if you set the prior case we're
all about products so our strategy is
very product oriented if that strategy
is right and if you're executing like
crazy there's there's some things that
still arise but if you get those three
right then the world is a great place
you need to make sure that you're
spending time doing the bigger picture
stuff the stuff that I call CEO time
because if all you're doing is being
stuck in the trenches you're never gonna
be able to build something much bigger
than yourself I love this message
because you get to see a CEO of a big
company of Apple sharing how he guides
the company forward his best use at this
time is making sure that he's allowing
the people on his team to thrive that
he's focusing on the strategy the bigger
picture things the execution and not
doing all of the dirty details himself
because that would not be again the best
use of this time and as an entrepreneur
you need to make sure that you're doing
the same thing for your business and I
get that it's hard I know it's hard
you're doing everything we mean the
janitor to the CEO of your business
you're doing the County you're doing
sales you're doing product development
you're working on your website there's a
lot that you have to do as an
entrepreneur and I get it but what's
really important that you have to do is
make sure that you allow for 90 minutes
a day at least of CEO time and I
recommend starting your day with it
before you get distracted before you get
emails before you get calls before you
open your computer
start checking out Outlook or Gmail
before you get bothered and distracted
by anything 90 minutes a day of CEO time
to help you focus on growing your
business you have to make sure you allow
time for that and your calendar because
if you don't you're gonna feel like
you're running and running and running
and never getting anywhere like that
hamster on the wheel so my question
today for you guys today is I want to
know how much CEO time are you spending
on average in your business
percentage-wise you look at all the
hours you're working in your company how
much of that is on doing the CEO
big-picture stuff versus the running of
the business something that maybe should
be given up to somebody else give me a
percentage leaving the comments below
I'm really curious to find out thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso